look I made some big mistakes mistakes
I'm here today to again apologize I mean
it was a real blind spot in my personal
behavior in my personal life and I've
worked very hard I've apologized to my
wife obviously in to my constituents our
unit submission Asst look I did these
things and I'm embarrassed by them I did
them with you know over an extended
period of time
I'm responsible for this behavior that
led us to be in this place but in many
ways things are not that much different
than they were yesterday I can tell you
that something may come out that are
true some things are not but here's
where I'm kind of you to try to grow up
I did many people have asked me what my
feelings are today about representing
the winner I think that a theory or
should we down anthony weiner taking
pictures of themselves very
and I can
now I'll be looking for other ways to
contribute my talent with God's help in
the hard work we will all be successful